Nicole who hasn't spoken no
um she had an interesting she said
something specifically about there was
something red pill or there's sort of
this um
guys want to be red pill but they don't
have the means or they don't have the
money or the status or the game can you
can you expand a little bit more on on
sort of this philosophy that yeah
not a philosophy that I had but as as I
feel like there's a lot of definitions
of like what red pill is so like maybe
we should establish the working
definition for this conversation my
perception of it is that
um it's a group of men who like want to
achieve great things right there's this
whole thing of like be disciplined make
money take care of yourself be in shape
like don't be beta
um so that they can attract lots of
women and basically be able to have
multiple girlfriends non-monogamy one
directionally right like full loyalty
from the woman but they may have like
multiple like Andrew Tate like that's
what I think of what I was saying is
that a lot of men I see who are like I'm
red pill like this is gonna be my
lifestyle it's like
bro you don't even have the money for
that like it's like one woman doesn't
want you and you want six women to want
you like Andrew Tate like say what you
will but like
it says something about men when like
multiple women are willing to be with
one man they're willing to share a man
because the pool of other men is so bad
and then we have these men that think
they're gonna be like the next Andrew
Tates like you have debt you don't
you're not in shape like what are you
talking about dude like they're out of
their minds these guys are delusional
then I'm saying a lot of these men that
like want to be red pill do not have the
means to be red pill in the sense of
like to be like Andrew Tate
no I think you're right for the most
part without I mean like would the other
ladies agree with that do you have a
disagreement with that one
I love Andrew Tate and and Christianity
I think they're amazing I think they're
so sexy
a group Nicole there are so many men out
there that are trying to be at that
caliber and they just aren't and they
walk around oh look at me look at this
ooh I want this woman that woman please
but I mean Amber you just said that you
love Andrew and Tristan Tate and
everything they're about but they're
also the kind of men that would say
amber if you run in only fans you need
to get 50 of your money to me because I
own your body
because you're with me
would you have a problem with that
we can come back here
[Laughter]
oh I don't know I don't know
part of the features and benefits of of
top shelf men but then when top shelf
men say to you like well I have I have
certain boundaries that I can't have you
cross
do this yeah I'm bringing in my own
money I'm doing my own thing
if I'm like
I don't know I'm so confused but then
you can't but then you can't be with an
Andrew Tate because that's part of the
package part of the package is you're
one of many women to him and that he has
like a large say over your life in
particular ways in exchange for the
lifestyle and sense of material security
and child support
I would do it why not
so you would abandon that value because
he's a high enough value man
yeah
interesting 110 I would
if I knew you're shaking your head
that's a no for you no it's a note oh go
ahead sorry Amber hell yeah I would do
it please easy okay but I mean like
you're also in a relationship with a guy
where you were a stay-at-home girlfriend
and he took care of you and you set
boundaries but what he wasn't high
enough value he didn't have enough money
he didn't have a Bugatti a certain color
yeah
I mean you had a problem with him when
he set boundaries but then you're also
saying but I love Andrew and Tristan
Tate and I will comply with the rules
that's emotionally tormented so it's a
little bit different okay all right you
can't have different standards like
here's the pro like men and women like
you can't have fluctuating like
standards like those are intrinsic to
you and you should be holding to your
standards your boundaries your values no
matter the the people around you
otherwise you're gonna be like over here
you're over there this guy that guy like
these are things boundaries and
standards those are for us those are for
us and other people who come to us we
say hey does that match not like oh I'm
gonna throw my values out
all right
the average woman's ego has been so over
inflated
because of the globalization of the
sexual Marketplace and Instagram and
constant Simpsons and comments and DMs I
mean
so we have a
all of these average or below average
women that are making these
outstanding demands about what they
won't settle for in a man and they need
to have
she's 200 plus pounds and you know sits
on her ass all day but she wants a guy
that's six feet tall and has six-pack
abs makes a six-figure income can pay
all our bills because she's getting her
in her ego inflated by guys and
guys on the street guys at the gym that
are looking at her or
on Instagram or any of these social
media so when I hear I constantly hear
women say things like I have my
standards I have my boundaries I'm not
going to settle for less than I deserve
I'm not gonna I know my worth and it's
like well
whether we like it or not we don't get
to dictate our own worth we the our
worth is determined by our worth is
determined by what somebody will pay for
it and what the market dictates
you don't get to Marsh out a junkyard
car on the front of a lot and just slap
a hundred thousand dollar sign on it
because that's what you think it's worth
it's whatever somebody will pay for it
mop's actually agreeing with your point
uh Nicole because I just have a problem
with with his uh so mop when you say
that a person's worth is determined by
all these things as a Christian where is
this
okay you're talking about like societal
oh on the sexual Marketplace fair I just
wanted to clear that up because you just
said a person not as a person's
self-worth and I was like red flag like
we're all beloved children of God our
worth is equal but in the socio-sexual
market okay fair either I disagree with
that but we don't do it
so let me ask you okay so let me ask the
ladies this question so you're all
single you know you're dating
um what what percentage of men that you
come across are you seeing as boyfriend
type of material like long-term you know
uh father of your children like whatever
it happens to be that you're looking for
like what percentage of men that you're
dating meet that category for you right
now
I'm only dating like one or two guys and
I would marry
them I mean like of the men that you've
dated let's say since the start of the
year like what like what percentage of
the men that you've that you've dealt
with would be that that long-term type
of relationship material I've only dated
like two guys this year and both of them
took off all the boxes
I would say so to a degree but like I
said before it's very hard
and what I do for a living
so what would happen if Playboy uh
Tristan Tate dm'd you tomorrow morning
and said hey you know I saw you on
Richard's show and I dig your Vibe you
know let's go out
100 go please so these so these two top
shelf men that you're with they wouldn't
matter then
it would still matter but like I would
give it a go with Tristan but they would
be invisible at that point so they're
really not talking about
oh you guys are putting me on the front
now I don't know well I mean you know
these are some difficult questions that
must be contemplated this is why we're
having this conversation
[Music]
um I mean uh Yes actually like I would
when there's a conflict between what you
say and what you do we must believe what
you do right
okay
okay so let's set Amber aside for a
second Shania out of all the guys that
you've dated in the past year how many
of them like what percentage of them
meet that category of long-term like a
guy that you would commit to
say 100
um like I said I am only dating for
long-term you know I'd love every single
guy that you've met is a top shelf man
well every anyone that I would pursue I
would see that there's a reason to
Pursuit was that like two dates three
dates I'll just keep talking to them
like I said I I'm surely down on at
least one date in the past year and been
like this guy's a goof he's never gonna
hear me hear from me ever again well you
said dating right like the guys that
have dated yeah but you realize when you
meet a guy in a dating app or something
or he approaches you and you swap
numbers and you go out with him you sit
down that's a date
okay sorry I had a different so when I'm
dating someone it's someone that I'm
continuously seen okay not like first
date that yeah like I'm talking about of
all the guys that you've met and dated
no never never mind the percentage is
way different okay so what is the
percentage of that point then
um probably like
seventy percent seventy percent would
meet them but I don't I haven't dated
that much this year so okay yeah Nicole
so um I would say this year
maybe
um
maybe 20
okay Jessica
okay I really hope you guys enjoyed that
clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out